I've never been married never been
engaged and I don't have any children
I've had three very long relationships I
feel that my age is kind of working
against me and I'm not really sure what
to do how old are you I'm 39 and you
want to have kids I would love to you're
39. are you okay with not having kids
because there's not a lot of guys that
are going to want to settle for 39
because they want a family you're not
going to be able to give them that right
yeah and I'm okay with that so what's
the goal the goal is to actually have
like a healthy profound relationship
with someone you've got to put yourself
out there it sounds like you got walls
built up around you from stuff that
happened in your life and you're not
giving yourself an opportunity to date
guys women have incredibly high
standards for men when it comes to
long-term relationships and they can
often end up in a scenario that you're
at right now where it's like okay you've
gotten a 39 you've dated a few guys some
of them were losers one or two of them
deceived you oh well big deal through
some dirt until you find the gold and
don't waste it on people that don't meet
your minimum requirements but don't have
exaggerated minimum requirements